right so thank you for coming here my
name is sadder russia i'm a co-founder
of a company called georgia later so
four years ago I moved from Japan to
Mountain View and found that there a
Silicon Valley company and we also open
sources this product called friendly so
i will talk about this so let's start
from very beginning here's our
high-level analytics system our texture
so of course you need to collect data
from servers mobile devices or even
smartwatches then store that to
somewhere that would very start point to
start datamatics then process that data
is in some tools there are many tools
like hi Prester our bedtime things then
visual the data then create some reports
so that you can decide something who are
improved versus your system this very
basic infrastructure in these days
especially in this three or four years I
think there are many tools created here
for storage and processing Hadoop is one
of the biggest thing and you you now
have a spark you also have a Preston and
to store data you can see HDFS I was 13
while Google Cloud storage system it's
very good for visualization in fact
excel as one of the best tool to
visualize the data then now you have
some other vehicles as such as the load
you can also use a machine learning
system there or you can or to view the
data using those adversities so now the
total time from the beginning to get the
results is shortened a lot thanks for
those technologies however if we focus
on this data collection it's still a
program i think that's some somewhere
wendy focuses on so when this solves the
data collections problem so for example
um
the decoration problem is like this you
have applications and you need to
collect data from those applications and
store that to HDFS or somewhere and
applications each applications have
different log formats or different
column different type and you need to
set up something for those applications
one by one and it's a very painful work
even if you set up once application
changes so you need to keep maintaining
the scripts and if we if this if the
application changes or the script is
blockin and data is not collected
correct appropriately the visualize
visualize the results will be broken so
you cannot trust the results so this
collection having a reliable data
collection state as the stable data
collection is very basically visiting
essential thing to make the results
profitable so for the the about the data
collection maybe this was three years
ago solution application servers have
files locally there is lot notation and
create files every hour then set up our
things SCP that contain to collect data
to a storage central storage that will
be like HDFS NFS EFTPS xtp whatever but
here a big problem was that this latency
is so high you need to wait for a
completion one file and completion of
the data transfer between the network
its high lengthy and during the data
transfer the network bandwidth is
consumed a lot so it could cause some
problems it could cause some problems on
your production environment and even if
the data is collected on the street is
still a file so you need to parse the
file but it's the processing is a hard
in the prepare up correct parsing law
clear and the processing itself also
text time you will run ma priest job or
hide recoveries to parse the data but
still takes like hour or even more so
before starting datalogix we have this
latency so you cannot leave the fresh
data you can't analyze the data in real
time way so it's a problem so to solve
this problem you might think about this
architecture what you are doing this
architecture create a script Chris a
script for each combination of the
inputs and outputs for example if you
have apache web server in jenks web
server you create a pool which tells the
log and for the data to Hadoop or even
have a elasticsearch hosted on amazon
okay create a new scripts to start send
data to Oscar search okay we want to
join data with data coming from mobile
devices you create on the login script
okay I want to join with Twitter streams
so that we can do more advanced data
analytics create a little script here
but this is very painful because you
need to maintain n multiplied by M
scripts so number of scripts increases a
lot as you want to do more advanced
accurate data analytics and those
scripts need to handle the common data
collection problems which is retrying
whether the handling broken records or
handling the duplicated reports were
buffering retrying dark entities and
let's say someone created this script
and unfortunately he leaves the company
and you need to take over that script
it's nightmare I won't do that well I
did do that several times but it's not
good so the true solution is this I
think so have a central have to correct
everything first this is the unified
voiding infrastructure
then set up this two for the loss to the
outputs with this way you don't have to
manage n by M scripts what you need is n
inputs class in our outputs so it's much
more scalable and if you'll see this
picture I think you will think about
that how calf car is different from this
architecture right in fact the last
station here buy Pinterest suggested
very good morning so yes cough can can
be here by the way but they also built a
tool called finger right so it handles
the log parsing and it has fallen
architecture to the application logs it
also handles the at least one mechanism
it means it has buffering locally and we
trying it also has handling for data
duplication it worse it has a field
training yet and when you you want to
copy the data from capital F 3 you also
create some other tools that that's
something presented before today right
so Christian was maybe do i need to
Chris singer again for our system it's
not because friendly solves the problem
print these open source project you can
use right now so let's go into their
friendly internal architecture so from
these are a plug-in based architecture f
so this is a bit simplified architecture
diagram because there are some more
plugins around it Parsa flowing from
what blurring but this is a basic
architecture so they are impt planning's
filter prevents powerpoints and other
plans so long here are all structures
like that so long has a time in the tag
which means which this log comes from
which data sources
and it has also a body which is JSON
formed and this time is is the time when
the log generated it's not the time when
the log is received that this time is
very important later and you will set a
time for each inputs so this log comes
from a waiver application this waiver
petition these log comes from system
stats this log comes from mobile devices
you said time for each data sources and
then body is Jason this is not text so
here's a one important principle of
friendly you should first laws first
before stirring them that's because
applications know about the data
structure that should be applications a
responsibility to format the log so that
data analytics can start immediately so
friendly usage JSON for the interior
system so the data is now structured it
has Jason body tag and kind and using
those events you can route the messages
to appropriate problems for example this
log coming from my sequel goes to this
field of one then convert the data will
enrich the data then goes to buffer
bragging this buffer plugin is
responsible to the make the performance
better or make sure that the data is
correct resend send it including
retrying and at least one some errands
then finally goes to the output
then here's some some more details about
input first input wizard vlogs or
employing can pull data from external
services periodically my example is in
HTTP input planning it reasons on our
port and accessed from accepts data from
web browsers others so one use case is
that a user so this input funny yeah
receive data or pull data from other
data sources yeah and one use case is
HTTP in plugging so one user uses
friendly at runs friendly instance on
ec2 they have a lot of servers bear and
put a javascript web beacon on web star
web pages there every time user accesses
to the web server the JavaScript loads
data to this friendly improving then you
can plan definitely in tone to route the
events to appropriate the output the
another input plugin is tailing pulling
it tells it reads data from a growing
file is that you have injects and you
the inject logs data to a file you don't
have to change engine example instead
friendly with the data automatically and
parses the logs and syslog is under
program of course and you can receive
data from other instances and point a
important here is that input training
should be non blocking so in la Goree
aggregation system we need to think
about the load of the network and
storage they could be unstable depending
on the traffic order system status but
even that time we need to make sure data
is stored eventually otherwise the
following analytics steps will be
unreliable we cannot trust the data we
make sure they that result is always
trust of all so
friendly it first receive the data
anyway even if the network is unstable
or the applicator the stretch is
overloaded it doesn't block it means it
means that even the loading system is
unstable it doesn't affect the
applications of course applications
should be the first priority loading is
the next even if loading is down
application should be running correctly
so input is non-voting it's important
point for data logging it then events
goes to filter plugins filter planning
transforms logs or filter out on the
salons or enrich the data so one plugin
often used is in data in encryption
plumbing so you have data including like
password or health care information you
don't want to store that somehow then
you can apply this plugin to end up to
date the data but at the later step you
can still decrypt the data because
that's an inclusion or another way is to
apply a hash function the data is
analyzed by this field top blogging but
still you can tell this is same with
this then this is this is most likely
acceptable for our data analytics data
statistics but still at the same time
you can satisfy the security requirement
so if your little plugin can do that and
the big use case is to convert IP to
regional information like countries or
areas this is also important for the
data analytics and you don't have to do
that on the later data analytic step I
think often cases you do this conversion
at the later etl steps but filter plugin
can do that in streaming way in real
time under this case is processing the
user agent so this is a firefox basis
from anything this can filter this can
convert the user agent information to
the browser type always type the
cramping combination of those is also
very important because let's say you
don't want to store the access logs of
bots you filter you apply a filter
plugin two-person horse user agent first
they applied another filter plumbing
that removes at this is from bots so you
can use mod to filter province and
enrich the data then data goes to a
buffer plugging the buffer problem is
for performance and reliability and
thread multithreading performance there
are two types of buffer plugins right
now why is it called memory plumbing and
the other is called flying so this
source data in memory of all file and
memory is of course faster but if you
use memory it becomes harder to operate
the system it makes it difficult to
restore the system or apply new code to
their system so then file is more
reliable it's slightly slower but the
performance difference is almost like
ten percent also because in most of the
cases data is in file cache so reading
data and writing data is done in memory
by Cornell they weren't stolen the
overhead is just a calling system call
resistant Coruscant that's it so it's
reliable and fast then things go to
output Levine's the outpouring just send
data to a somewhere important point here
is I think customization you have many
number of strategies I think depending
on the use cases now you have search
engines datil nautical systems and of
course you also have a postal scale
Mexico you want to sync those data using
out plugin you can plug in out plugins
well blonde is file one prong is s3
another its MongoDB and there
hand rails province released as open
source you can fork those open source
projects to create under plumbing or of
course you can create from scratch it's
clogging based system so in those
plug-in architecture important thing is
extensibility customizability so that
friendly can handle the directory
integration to your application to the
lodging system and but this buffer
program is a bit different this doesn't
handle the integration of application
logic instead this handle the
reliability but in fact this is one of
the most important component in finding
so friendly uses this buffer
architecture a buffer has chunks in it
one chance throws several logs in it and
input plugins write data to the latest
chunk and out plugins read data from the
oldest chunk it's in its to dab so this
means that even if output is blocked or
not working well input can still write
data to the latest chunk and time passes
like 10 seconds or so you can go over
here or size of a champ exceed certain
threshold like 10 megabytes it creates a
new chunk then stood up then output is
done by chunk by chunk basis so it's
more more like much so if you write data
one by one row by row basis is slow but
because friendly text care with this
buffering it's much more faster and more
important that it's stable so if input
is faster then the output through pit is
a problem of course it was this queue
growth and growth but the traffic is not
consistent every time
or it can be traffic can have big time
and I don't crying then bart XTL the
leveling of the traffic when the traffic
is a high it kills up and sizable chunk
becomes bigger then output right the big
chunks to the output at the maximum
scrupled then if the traffic becomes
idling chunk size will be smaller then
it's more with a real time you can trust
a there every second or every two
seconds of your soul so this plugin is
for buffer plans for performance and
reliability this is also important for
the network transfer I mean distributed
system so if you think about the batch
oriented this kind of data transfer the
it means to retry from the beginning if
a problem happens let's say there's a
network problem it needs to retry from
the beginning and there is a broken data
somehow then you need to eat right from
the beginning then sending all data
takes many long time but because
friendly divides the data into chunks
the impact on the error is small so you
can make the loading system more
reliable and let's say there's a broken
data you cannot send or the storage
cannot store other case a friendiy has a
feature called secondary so that if out
could gives up throwing the data you can
move the data to another storage let's
say somehow lost sword cannot straw data
for one hour then friend these secondary
plugins towards the data to a three it's
a fullback path that you can recover it
later so it's chunk by chunk basis so
buffering is very important feature here
so let's go into some more specific
examples
once this very typical so you have web
server and write data to access logs
oxyglow pile and most of the cases you
have some customization there the log is
not common approach format but has some
extra headers in there at the end then
you use tail plug in with some other
customization here and configuring here
when details that later as it gloves and
the friendly writes data to buffer
chunks and if you use file buffer the
data buffer chunks or persistent on a
disk then use out of the plug going to
write data to elasticsearch or other
storages and here again if this is
unstable friendly with rice the sending
it it it guarantees at least once of
course it has a exponential weight so
that it doesn't cause the two much
problems and then when you think about
log file collection tailing from a long
while you need to take care of the log
rotation it's actually tricky problem
about writes data to a file but if a
size of this file exceeds certain
threshold but will create a new file
then old file will be moved to another
fire from the also takes care of this
program but in fact if you write a
script to do this it's tricky so
friendly creates a file called post fire
plus five stores the last location over
the file so that the next polling can
read from that position and it also
stores the inode number over the fire so
friendly can detect the log rotation by
checking the I know the difference there
so in peril in texture with that problem
and also you can plug in those parser
proteins here i used up our chat example
but there are plugins for apache deborah
rocks or JSON format csv format
what's this law okay this is also very
common use case you have application
here something here buffer data and
route the events to multiple locations
it's very common you have recent data on
elasticsearch splunk those search
engines so that you can look up recent
data very quickly but on the other hand
it's hard to scale those system or
perhaps you need to pay more to scale
the system but you don't need the old
data on those sore changes what unit is
recent data only so you can see friendly
to configure the system wendy has a
copying planning to send data to
multiple locations it's as the matter
out clubbing so there's an output plugin
called copy it receives data first then
that meta output plugging write data to
other out of plugins multiple times
and friendly also supports local folding
so you have each wave servers hundreds
hundreds of web servers first then you
can aggregate those are those logs into
aggregation servers there at this point
what unit here is the reliability of the
aggregation solvers you need to think
about load balancing and HEA and
failover this friendly plugin called out
for takes care of it if this out plugin
keep standing keeps sending the
heartbeat between other from the
instances then if it detects a failure
of a server it first dated to another or
from the instances and if you store data
on HDFS and process the data using hive
this partitioning results are important
type of assumes data is partitioned by
our lab ID so that you don't have to
read all data every time but problem
here that it is be guaranteed that this
file doesn't include logs from the other
hours otherwise the result will be
blogging or that you need to read more
files to guarantee that all data is in a
file so here friendly uses the time when
logged generated log produced to torsion
those files even if the log folding
delays it guarantees the logs are in the
file with the producer time so you can
immediately set about our hearts hanging
on the collect data collected from the
friendly so you can immediately restore
the data analytics here if you are a
three instead of other work placement of
a gfs same thing yet three plugin also
slices the files by the hour
and as I explained that's plug-in
architecture and it's open source
product many so the there are three or
four quad developers including me coming
from cellular companies and they are a
pretty big development community for the
twenty core and there are much larger
community for creating plugins they're
hundreds of plugins released on the web
one user wanted to integrate with DES
com they wanted to collect data from
this calm and the sort store the data to
start changing so that they can sort
that it gets easily and the person
wanted to collect data from cover and
there are many use cases for its user
and all of them are released as a
plugins so you can install it all to the
same one is I wanted to put the data to
zabbix because they have some Xperia you
have this system we want to integrate
the logs with using Flynn d you can
search on the friendly website these are
list of plugins released probably that's
already there you find one even you
cannot find you can customize those
existing one and create a new plug-in
based on that so it's you almost don't
have to create from scratch so there are
some real work use cases more high-level
use cases so one user collects data from
mobile or web servers and that is add
add locks ad impression logs they store
data to forge editor which is
cloud-based data processing service and
then they have hundreds of servers here
and aggregate the data to tens of
servers then send data to throw you
later a point is that because this is a
chair supported and buffering support
and at least once is guaranteed by
friendy they didn't have to write code
there is this is also very common plug
use kiss hot data goes to start changing
and cold data goes to HDFS as archive
this is an example configuration so here
you have source source much those two
source and match it they are two major
configuration source describes the input
here you have two inputs moines bill
tailing from file here is poss file
which records by a last position and
form updates apache and you can also
customize here to write a very XP and
tag the data with this name be able to
access then you can match with this tag
to further laws to somewhere or filter
the data using fruit of Levine's here we
use copy blogging and write the data to
two locations one in the elastic search
mines HDFS here's another source this
receives data from other plenty
instances or you can use client
libraries like crying library for Ruby
crime lab for Python client live life
for java to send data directory to
friend be a streaming data processing is
another major thing so there's a well
first of all there is a product called
Esper do you know about Esper maybe not
okay it's actually historical old
product much you're very much short
product it can run sequel on top of the
streaming data it's a it's Java I mean a
Java product and one company bags the
product Marie Curie is a integration
between friend e and s / which means
that you can apply sequel to the
streaming later this is for many
purposes for example you want to detect
Annamarie from the web access then you
can apply one sequel to process the data
and if the secret finds something weird
it puts data back to friendly and use
ended up having to send email to send
notification to the bigs or send
notification to assess that comment
integration will be in trendy here's
another thing a docker container can
send data directory too friendly so in
fact if you install docker it comes with
friendly loading module bundled in it
when you start dr. Whitcomb online is
you can specify the output location and
you can say friend d column space the
localhost blah blah blah Justin logs to
friend d then you can aggregate those
data to some aggregation servers and the
same day that with those services using
the integration proteins and a some
Giants I mean enterprise companies are
using friendly internally so this is one
example so Microsoft is using trendy for
their low collection so I think
Microsoft is changing recently I think
Microsoft had a log collection system
for windows of course it makes sense but
they needed to create low correction for
linux or other open source middleware
then they use they choose friendy of the
infrastructure so in turn our ETA is
friendly and package it as ons agent
then they distribute this product to
their customers so they said the having
hundreds of existing plumbing help them
a lot
so here's a Russian a company behind
confluence and JIRA hipchat being bit
budget so here's this very good example
they use kinases to to control the flow
of the logs but still install friendly
on those edge servers to takes care of
the twist ones and load parsing problems
and the buffering problems because we
can think kafka instead proteinosis they
are very similar system so this
combination help them in the Amazon Web
Services also uses friendiy and
recommend them it to their users it's
it's it's actually documented on amazon
so so i think i mean in terms technology
i think this is good technology and I
this is one of the most successful
project i started but and it's used for
those big companies and one deployment a
two hundred to two hundred thousand
solvers all of them deploy if friendly
it means one of the biggest computing
computing cluster in the world deploy is
friendly to the old servers so I think
it's proven technology but unfortunately
it's not so well known right now it's a
problem so I think friend is not for not
only for those big big users but this is
for everyone so at the last I want to
say that please let your friends know
about this friendly at this weekend how
good it is good it looks like maybe and
and another thing that so we try later
as a company supports this friendly
project we are the biggest supporter of
the friendly project and we are looking
for a sort of evangelist
to let people know about friendly I
think technology is good but people
don't know about that so please contact
us if you're interested in the
evangelism work and with a good salary
so okay that's it thank you very much I
think we had we can have some questions
I have a question on your buffer
chunking you said you know based on the
traffic you resize the chunk so how do
you use any prediction algorithm or
what's the model you use behind that
it's based on the sizable chunk is based
on your configuration they're they're
not smart album in fact it's based on
size or time which are either that the
first satisfied so if yes it is pretty
tummy you need to configure it actually
the way do you have some are just
suggestions to
right right right I see so a typical
configuration that make the maximum
limit large so you can buffer at the
most 4 gigabytes as long as this is
there and make the buffer size small and
make the time long it's this compression
and it works mostly well alright so I
had a question about basically buffering
data helps you know like throughput but
on the other hand you want your like
data to be available to the like
downstream sources as fast as available
so you know like if you keep uploading
new files to s3 that's going to like for
example lead in a lot of files so you
might need some like compaction process
or something I does fluently support
like compaction out of the box no it's
it's actually very difficult program so
so one I so won architecture people do
is that I use one plugging with short
rushing trouble to send data to
real-time search like elastic source
puck and use longer flashing total to
send data to a 3 this is 4 I'll Drive it
so having copy plugging and different
buffer setting mostly solves the problem
well in fact another solution that we
provide data on Alex as a service so
it's a sign up and send data and we do
their compassion
someone else so do you do any data
format transformation type of thing just
data format to parse the data of yellow
you're getting like unified not layers
so you're getting all kinds of deep not
and then do you do anything on top of
them just snack store and flash to s3
Isaac yes so yeah data format is I think
to location wise output side and the
other i simplified and for other side
yes there there plans in fact i simplify
the architecture there's input and
output but in fact they are for
multiplying next to the output blogging
so you can plug in the format appliance
to use Europe moment an input this thing
there are also plugins to post mineus
other fonts and internally it uses well
we say it's jason its stimulus data
format but you actually its message back
its binary efficient format